and finally new role moving forward
every previously unwritten rule about
the presidency must be written down if
Donald Trump has taught everyone who
ever dealt with him one thing it's get
it in writing and the American people
are just the latest suckers to learn
that the hard way
the Declaration of Independence starts
with the words we hold these truths to
be self-evident self-evident because the
founders assumed some things were so
obviously repugnant they would just be
covered by a sense of shame and these
were guys who owned slaves
but Trump reminds us that some people
will break every rule that's not
specifically enumerated from inviting
Russian spies into the Oval Office to
not releasing his taxes from insisting
law enforcement be loyal to him
personally to maintaining a for-profit
business empire while in office we are
learning nothing is just understood
anymore it's like when they write do not
eat on silica gel packs
I wouldn't eat one but apparently some
people open a shipping box and say great
my new sneakers are here and they came
with snacks when you're a babysitter
when you hire a babysitter you write
down a list of rules no boyfriend visits
no loud music stay out of my greenhouse
but no one thinks they have to write
down don't put the baby in the microwave
well with Trump you do he reminds me of
that Disney movie
Gus remember Gus about a mule who's
signed by a football team to be their
kicker you see because the rule book
never specifically said that the players
had to be human and that's true
it is he's the owner of a football team
who signs a mule because it doesn't
explicitly say he can't you think he's
gonna release his tax returns just
because the others did not as long as
Gus keeps kicking those field gold
presidents certainly have the right to a
point who they want to top posts but we
forgot to write down ok but they can't
all go to your son-in-law nepotism is
fine if you're a junk dealer like on
Sanford and Son
it's not fine when NATO is a conference
on bioterrorism and you send your
daughter the purse designer American
presidents every one of them just knew
it was the right thing to divest
themselves of all business holdings if
they were so honored as to become
president because we don't want a
president who's got his mind on his
money and his money on his mind Jimmy
Jimmy Carter's sold his peanut farm
George Bush sold his baseball team Sarah
Palin closed down her meth lab
[Applause]
we did not elect a swamp draining
reformer we gave our pin number to a
Nigerian prince there is no more
self-evident we didn't think we had to
write down when Russians or Nazis attack
America side with America we didn't
think we had to write down don't run
your crime family from the Oval Office
don't threaten to throw your political
opponents in jail don't talk [ __ ] in
front of children
don't well [ __ ] I don't even know what
this is but don't do it
and finally a question that is asked a
lot lately is can a president pardon
himself and again we don't know since no
one ever had the balls or the bad taste
to try because Madison and Jefferson
never thought the executive branch would
fall into the hands of a mule that plays
football
but Trump actually asked his staff he
said can I pardon myself and Steve
Bannon told him why not I can blow
myself